so Muhammad Ali is probably one of the
great 20th century representatives of
Islam
um for me personally at least hopefully
I'm not strong my bias one of the great
modern Representatives is uh khabib
nurmagomedov who's a great fighter and a
great human being so you've gotten a
chance to meet him uh I should also say
your friends your good friends with a
lot of really interesting Muslim people
I mean it's just it's such a widespread
religion there's just so much variety of
different people that are practicing
Muslims so um what uh does khabib
represent what do you like about him as
a Muslim what do you like about him as a
person as representative of the religion
I think I think Habib
first of all he is a great person you
know humble person he's shown and now
Islam as well kind of following in that
they're really showing the beauty of
faith in their lives their culture their
values
um everything from the way that he
carried himself in a principled way
uh you know like like every Muslim kid
grew up in a public school cafeteria
before Islamic schools were a thing in
the United States not eating pork for
example and kind of being the odd person
out
so when you got a fighter in uh
in in the UFC scene and doesn't drink
alcohol kind of maintains like a very
um
consistent principles
uh you know attachment to his religion
it really is inspiring growing up we had
Hakeem Olajuwon in the 1990s basketball
who was fasting in the NBA I think Habib
was is that for a lot of people a lot of
young people today and and people in
general and I think beyond that uh the
values
how he honored his father
and how he honors his mother and how he
continues to put family first that's a
beautiful part of Islam that's a
beautiful part of our value system
we have a lot of emphasis on family
family is Central to Islam and his
honoring of his father was so beautiful
and again what he's willing to do for
his mother
you know it's just so beautiful and I
think that we saw it frankly even with
Morocco in the World Cup
you know there is a lot of islamophobia
in this recent World Cup episode you
know a lot of the criticism of Qatar
while no government is beyond reproach
uh certainly no government is beyond
reproach but had very obvious blatance
islamophobic undertones and then with
Morocco Rising being the first African
Muslim uh Arab team you know to get that
far in the World Cup what did you see
beyond the consistent honoring of
Palestine you also saw the honoring of
the mothers every single time the game
would end they go into a prostration of
gratitude so just like we prostrate in
prayer a prostration of gratitude
and then they go and they kiss their
mother's foreheads dance with their
mothers on the field hug their moms and
honor their moms that's Islam for you
khabib after his fight what does he do
he prostrates
points up to the heavens it's God and
then he prostrates
the whole Moroccan team beautifully
prostrates uh even when they lost they
prostrated out of gratitude they honored
their mothers
so I think sometimes athletes are able
to demonstrate some of these beautiful
values of Islam in a way that the world
can maybe see them in a different light
the values of humility and the values of
love
love broadly but love for family and and
look how everyone around Habib talks
about him right no one ever no one ever
says he's a jerk no one ever says he's
mistreated them they've all got stories
right and that's what a beautiful Muslim
does a beautiful human being you treat
the people in such a way that all these
stories come out later of how good you
were to everyone that came into contact
with you and Habib was that person uh he
is that person he does a great job of
treating people with a lot of respect
obviously no one is perfect right I mean
imperfections are for everybody but
I definitely think that um he did a
beautiful job representing
his faith in those moments
um you know beyond punching people in
the face that's kind of a different
subject
smashing faces not the Smashing faces
part the prostration part and the
humility I tell you man he's not humble
in the ring right he's uh he he would
Maul his opponents right but I mean as
as a practitioner as a fan of the sport
of all grappling sports for me there's
also a beauty to the art of uh grappling
and and the fighting sports but yes
um I think his again humility his honor
uh outside the cage is uh his exemplary
and the money the fame the power hasn't
changed the man no not at all and that's
that's actually I think the most
beautiful part when I met him
um I found him to be
as humble as he is on screen and that's
always very endearing and all the
stories of the people that have been
around him for a much longer time very
humble man I pray for him honestly I
pray for Islam I pray for that family
um that God keeps them grounded and
protected and together
um and that they maintain that beautiful
spirit because even if you if you just
watch the lead up of to the last uh the
last fight with Islam just the way they
carry themselves their day to day you
know they never relinquish their prayers
they never relinquish their family uh
ties the things that make them who they
are to be better Fighters because they
don't see
that uh they have to let go of those
things in fact they attribute all of
their worldly success
uh to that that faith and so you know
beautiful examples and I think that uh
it's good for young Muslims to see
themselves in that and it's good for
other people to see Islam uh through
that as well